(bright music)
- [Narrator] Nobody's born smart.
We all start at zero.
Can't talk, can't walk,
certainly can't do algebra.
Adding, reading, writing,
riding a bike,
nobody's good at anything at first.
There was a time when
Einstein couldn't count to 10
and Shakespeare had to learn his ABCs
just like the rest of us.
Thankfully, we're born to learn.
Slowly, surely, you stumble, slip, crawl,
fall, and fail, and fall,
frustrating, confusing,
trying, struggling,
until one day, you walk.
One foot in front of the other.
One idea on top of the next.
Each wrong answer making your
brain a little bit stronger.
Failing is just another word for growing
and you keep going.
This is learning.
Knowing that you'll get it
even if you haven't gotten it yet.
Because the most
beautiful, complex concepts
in the whole universe
are built on basic ideas
that anyone anywhere can understand.
Whoever you are, wherever you are,
you only have to know one thing,
you can learn anything.